China's economic growth is set to fall
behind the rest of Asia for the first
time since 1990 according to the World
Bank it expects the Chinese economy to
grow 2.8 percent this year nearly half
of what was previously forecast The
Slowdown is largely due to a downturn of
the property Market in beijing's zero
covid policy the World Bank cut its
forecast for the asia-pacific region as
a whole to 3.2 percent
we're joined Now by our China analyst
Clifford coonan good to have you so in
more evidence that the world has turned
upside down the rest of Asia Clifford is
doing better than China what are the
prospects of the Chinese economy now
it's funny have we gotten so used to
China being the the leader and and the
the strong growth uh figures coming from
there
um I think that there's a lot of
challenges facing the Chinese economy
right now um we have the zero covert
policy as you've mentioned
um this is interesting when you compare
it to other countries which have also
had quite strict covert policies but
seem to have managed it better without
these shutdowns that they've had in
China which have caused played Havoc
with with the economy
um there's 23 countries in the region
and China accounts for 86 percent of
economic output so whatever way you look
at it we need China to keep growing but
um it's uh it's also facing the the
prospect of a 20th party Congress coming
up which the leader Xi Jinping will
reinforce his his Rule and that's also
means that there's not much happening in
China everything has to kind of stay as
it is in terms in economic terms and
then we have a problem facing the the
property sector which accounts for about
30 percent of economic activity and
that's also in trouble at the moment so
there's a lot of headwinds facing China
right now never a good time for a cut in
a forecast but this timing is especially
inauspicious so this is a huge cut in
the forecast for region long considered
the engine of global growth what does
this mean for the global economy then
well I think it's going to be
interesting I mean if you cast your mind
back to the 90s when we were talking
about the tiger economies I mean Vietnam
was the fastest growing region uh sorry
country in the region
um I think we're going to see more
growth coming from other economies as we
say China is still a giant in the region
but um I think uh the rest of the world
still needs China it still needs
um its its output it still needs it's
such a key factor in the supply chain
and
um ultimately we need China to recover
in order for the for the global economy
to to recover uh I think the prospects
going forward forward all depends on how
how Zero covid moves if Xi Jinping
decides to keep it going that's what
everyone's worried about at the moment
because people are hoping for a stimulus
plan perhaps in China which won't happen
as long as zero covert is happening
because it will just fizzle out so I
think um how does zero covert policy
develops in China is going to be
absolutely crucial to seeing how the
economy develops rest of the world still
needs China for a better worse Clifford
coonan thanks so much much